so here we go in game four a dramatic
game three victory for the oakland a's
to force a game four and we'll see what
we get from granky
and that's on the ground right side
altuve ranging to the outfield grass
spins and fires what a nice play by jose
altuve from short right field grinky has
one two three first so two on with one
away here as the 80s put together
back-to-back singles
saw this with granby during the regular
season he will
show what he's going to throw
this is driven in the air to left field
back goes tucker he is at the wall that
ball is gone
back deep into the pavilion and left a
blast for l'oreal
and a three-nothing lead for the oakland
a's in the second inning
so granky shows him what he's going to
throw him and then this one goes out of
the yard for the a's and the home runs
continue
[Applause]
on the ground left side and simeon will
flip the second for one on to first for
two double play
nicely done six four three on the twin
killing we head to the bottom of the
third inning
guriel leading it off here now for the
astros looking at the first pitch skies
one to right
and short right that is estella out
canada in and out and dropping the ball
is olson and heading to second base is
guerrielle he'll get there
for the astros need to get on the board
handed an opportunity here with the
error
swing of the miss and he struck him out
a very defensive swing by maldonado
strikes out and here's the first k of
the day for montas
i'm sure if you're bob melvin you hope
he stays right here and can give you six
innings springer waves at that and
strikes out and mo toss comes up huge
with the man at third base
and shuts down the astros again playing
him
in the air to right field that is deep
to the corner goes reddick got the wall
he leaps and redick is
come up with it he makes the grab in the
corner and holds on
made the catch rattled up against the
wall and somehow held on to the baseball
nice catch by reddick wasn't entirely
sure
[Music]
took a home away home run away from him
3-1 to brantley
[Music]
and he sends one to right field and deep
back goes canna at the wall that ball is
gone
a two-run home run for bradley and back
come the astros it's a one-run game now
michael bradley
home run to right field it's 3-2
athletics but here come the astros
bregman stops at second and the astros
have runners in first and second with
nobody out
and it's driven a deep left field for
correa grossman going back and that ball
is long gone
a three-run home run puts the astros on
top five to three
carlos correa with his third home run of
the series
this location and he hammered it
you knew it frankie says that the mount
is up to his specifications now ray
and he delivers to laureano
this is driven out towards deep left
field off the bat of floriano he went
deep earlier he goes deep again
very good to left for loriano
oakland a's answer with a run very
quickly here in the fifth after the five
run fourth by the astros and it's now
five to four second home run of the day
for loriano
tosh giving up the five runs in three
and two thirds before he left seven hits
walked one struck out three
here's a drive to deep right field back
goes canna he is at the wall and that
ball is gone another home run michael
brandley hits his second of the day
houston astros on top by two again it's
six to four
two run shot for him in the fourth solo
shot here in the fifth for michael
bradley
first in third with nobody out and
correa coming up
this is lined into left field a base hit
for correa from third comes bregman with
the seventh astros run of the day
houston on top now seven to four the
astros have runners in first and second
this one is lying into center field to
base hit and coming around from second
base is altuve trying to score the throw
goes to second and he will score putting
the astros on top eight to four as they
add on here in the bottom of the sixth
inning
now he lights one into right field for a
base hit brantley will be waved around
cannon's throw is going to be cut off
and the astros take a 9-4 lead
altuve will hit this in the air to
center field loriano going back at the
wall that will carry out of here
jose altuve hits a two-run home run and
it's 11-4 now astros
their fourth home run of the day belongs
to jose altuve
ryan presley the closer for the astros
in with a seven-run lead
it's on the ground to first base off the
glove of guriel a ronald score and
reaching at first base is lustela and
it's now 11-6
he's just trying to get that tying run
to the plate somehow here in the ninth
inning with two down
that is strike three and the houston
astros are heading to the american
league championship series